cuáles de los siguientes enunciados son
verdaderos de las siguientes gráficas y
es igual a 3 que multiplica a x menos 5
al cuadrado más uno es igual a 3 que
multiplica a x más 5 elevado al cuadrado
más 1 y antes de ver los enunciados
quiero recordar un poco lo que ya hemos
visto en varios vídeos lo primero que
quiero hacer es un pequeño análisis de
estas dos gráficas fíjate bien si tengo
esta de aquí cualquier valor que tome x
5 elevado al cuadrado siempre es mayor o
igual que 0 porque si te tomas cualquier
número y le suma 5 y lo llevas al
cuadrado siempre te va a dar algo mayor
o igual a 0 y más aún de hecho esta
expresión se hace mínima cuando esto que
está dentro del paréntesis se hace cero
es decir cuando esto x está dentro del
paréntesis se hace 0 10 vale 1 y de
igual manera para que adentro a
cualquier número si tú le restas 5 y lo
llevas al cuadrado te va a dar algo
mayor o igual que 0 y por lo tanto si
queremos saber pues el valor mínimo que
puede tomar esta gráfica pues eso se da
cuando esta expresión se hace cero y
entonces y va a ser igual a 1 todo esto
sería 0 simple sencillamente me quedaría
que es igual a 1 y este es el valor más
pequeño que puede tener mi gráfica estos
dos conceptos son muy importantes porque
en cualquier otro caso los valores van
salir más grandes y es más vamos a
intentar hacer la gráfica de estas dos
funciones en este plano cartesiano que
voy a dibujar aquí y bueno lo primero
que quiero que veas es qué pasa con
gráficas como x 4 además 1 no voy a
tomar primero no estas gráficas que
tengo aquí sino algo mucho más sencillo
para ir poco a poco viendo cómo podemos
llegar a estas expresiones que tenemos
acá y bueno la primera gráfica que
quiero que no hicimos es esta de aquí
pero esto no parece una palabra perdón
quedó horrible y ahora si esta de aquí
le voy a llamar x cuadrada + 1 es la
gráfica cuyo vértice está en el 1 y
además abre hacia arriba es decir es
cuadrada más uno ahora a partir de aquí
quiero que sigamos la misma idea que es
lo que va a pasar si primero ya se voy a
multiplicar a esta gráfica por tres es
decir quiero ver que me sale de la
gráfica 3x cuadrada + 1 como se va a ver
eso pues será una gráfica que crece
mucho más rápido porque me quedaría 3 x
x cuadrada más 1 y 3 es un número muy
rápido por lo tanto esto hace que mi
gráfica se apriete un poco más sigue
teniendo el vértice en el 0.1 y la única
diferencia de esta gráfica a la inicial
es que ésta crece mucho más rápido pues
tenemos el coeficiente de 3
multiplicando a la x cuadrada ahora lo
que mueve preguntar es qué es lo que
pasa con la gráfica y es igual a 3 que
multiplica a x menos 5 elevado al
cuadrado más 1 y creo que te das cuenta
de algo muy importante cuando esta
expresión se hace 0 es cuando x vale 5
cuando x vale 5 esto se hace 0 y
solamente me queda que lleva 1 eso
quiere decir que estamos recorriendo
esta misma gráfica 5 unidades hacia la
derecha de hecho va a ser exactamente la
misma temática que 3 x 4 damas 1 pero el
vértice lo hemos desplazado cinco
unidades a la derecha y por lo tanto
esta es la gráfica de la expresión 3 que
multiplica x menos cinco elevado al
cuadrado más uno y date cuenta que se
recorrió hace la derecha cinco unidades
porque cuando x vale 5 en la expresión
que está dentro del paréntesis se hace 0
esto es un buen tip para que podamos
graficar cualquier tipo de estas
expresiones ahora lo que quiero que veas
es que lo que va a pasar con la otra
gráfica y es igual a 3 que multiplica a
x + 5 elevado al cuadrado más 1 pues de
manera análoga esto se hace 0 cuando x
vale menos 5 por lo tanto va a ser la
misma gráfica que 3x cuadrada más uno va
a tener la misma forma solamente que el
vértice va estar recorrido o desplazado
cinco unidades hacia la izquierda
esta es la gráfica de tres que
multiplica a x más 5 elevado al cuadrado
y todo esto más 1 y ya con eso tengo las
dos gráficas y entonces el inciso a me
dice estos vértices que tenemos de tus
parábolas son máximos es verdadera esta
expresión y bueno un máximo se ve así
entonces yo veo que éstos no son máximos
porque las gráficas bajan llegan a un
punto y después suben y esto es
precisamente la definición de lo
contrario
por lo tanto esta expresión no es
verdadera y vámonos al siguiente sitio
dice las gráficas tienen la misma forma
pero diferentes vértices esto es
verdadero las gráficas tienen la forma
de 3x cuadrada y lo único que pasó es
que su vez y se desplazó tanto a la
derecha como a la izquierda es justo lo
que nos dice el inciso b y el inciso c
por lo tanto es falso pues nos está
diciendo que las gráficas tienen formas
distintas y sonante y el sentido y el
inciso de también es falso porque nos
habla de puntos máximos de vértices
máximos y mis dos parábolas que acabo de
encontrar tenían puntos mínimos así que
vamos a ver otro problema el problema 37
y dice en qué puntos y es más déjame
mejor
copiar y pegar este problema que tengo
aquí así que ya lo tengo aquí y dice
cuáles son los puntos en los cuales
interpretamos al eje de las x de la
gráfica es igual a 12 x cuadrada menos 5
x menos 2 y bueno no sé cómo se ve la
gráfica de esta función pero se va a ver
más o menos así es una cuadrática que
abre hacia arriba entonces se va a ver
algo así y yo lo que busco es unos
puntos sección con el eje de las x es
decir este y este y esto ocurre cuando
vale cero cuando ya vale cero estamos en
los puntos de intersección con las leyes
las equis pues cuando lleva la 0 no subo
ni bajó nada es decir estoy en el eje de
las x por lo tanto me queda que tengo
que resolver la siguiente ecuación 0 es
igual a 12 x cuadrada menos 5 x menos 20
es igual a 12 x cuadrada menos 5 x menos
2 y si te das cuenta esta expresión que
tengo aquí no está nada sencilla de
factorizar porque tenemos un 12 al lado
de la x cuadrada por lo tanto factorizar
esta expresión no creo que sea la mejor
opción y mejor lo voy a resolver por la
fórmula general que nos dice menos b
pero en este caso vale menos 5 entonces
me queda 5 positivo más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 5 al
cuadrado es 25 menos cuatro veces a por
c menos 4 por 12 x menos 2 porque se
vale menos 2 x menos 2 y de una vez
menos por menos me da más entonces estos
dos se hacen más ya todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre dos veces am es decir
entre 24 y que me queda de esto bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que cinco más
menos la raíz cuadrada de 25 más 4 por
12 por 2 esto es lo mismo que 4 por 12
es 48 por 2 es 96 4 por 12 por 12 96 8
por 12 96 entonces 25 96 entre 24 y esto
a cuánto es igual bueno me va a quedar
25 96 esto es lo mismo que 121 y la raíz
de 121 es exacta esto es lo mismo que 5
más menos 11 entre 24 y está de lujo
porque 121 tiene raíz cuadrada exacto y
bueno ya con esto vamos a poder
encontrar las dos raíces que me van a
dar las intersecciones con el eje de las
equis así que vamos a terminar este
problema me queda 5
11 / 24 este es mi primer raíz 5 11
entre 24 y esto es igual a 16 entre 24 y
si saco octava arriba yo estaba abajo me
quedan dos tercios tercios esto no
parece un 3 2 tercios esta es mi primera
raíz así que voy a decir que es este de
aquí y mi segunda raíz es 5 menos ahora
voy a tomar el signo menos menos 11
entre 20 y 45 menos 11 menos 6 y esto es
dividido entre 24 y si yo saco sexta me
queda menos un cuarto es decir este que
tengo aquí cuando x vale menos un cuarto
esta gráfica intersecta al eje de las x
en el punto menos 140 entonces aquí ya
tengo mi segunda raíz y ya resuelve este
problema perfecto ya tengo el problema
37 la respuesta es el inciso c así que
nos da tiempo de hacer otro más y yo no
tenemos un problema porque hay muchos
gráficos así que déjame achicar un poco
estos gráficos y ya que los tengo un
poco pequeños copiarlos y los copian en
el portapapeles que no me sirven de
mucho
carlos por acá entonces déjame intentar
pegarlos por aquí ya está perfecto y
bueno no cabe justo aquí déjame ver la
pantalla a jalar esta imagen no cabe
pero podemos empezar a mover la pantalla
esto está más o menos así y me preguntan
y bueno voy a tachar todo esto de aquí
para que no nos confundamos para que nos
quede mucho más claro todo esto y
entonces esto vamos a eliminarlo y me
preguntan cuál de estas gráficas es la
verdadera gráfica de la función y es
igual a menos 2 que multiplica a x menos
un elevado al cuadrado más 1 y tenemos 4
gráficas y lo que queremos saber es cuál
es la correcta así que lo primero que
quiero que te fijes es qué es lo que
pasaba con la ecuación y es igual a
menos 2 x cuadrada más 1 antes de pensar
para donde se desplaza lo que quiero ver
y analizar es qué pasa con esta ecuación
y lo primero que quiero que te des
cuenta es que esta expresión x menos uno
se desplaza uno hacia la derecha porque
cuando x vale 1 entonces x menos 1
elevado al cuadrado es 0 que es justo lo
que queríamos y además si esto vale 0
entonces se desplaza uno hacia arriba es
decir mi vértice está cuando que vale 1
nos desplazamos 1 hacia la derecha nos
desplazamos 1 hacia arriba y bueno ahora
quiero que analicemos la diferencia
entre esta función y es igual a x
cuadrada más 1 la función es igual a
menos 2 x cuadrada más 1 y lo que cambia
es el signo mientras aquí tenemos al 2
positivo al lado de la equis cuadrada
aquí tenemos al 2 negativo al lado de la
x cuadrada y lo que quiere decir es que
la de arriba abre hacia arriba como el
12 es positivo abre hacia arriba y la de
abajo es una parábola que abre hacia
abajo porque el coeficiente que está al
lado de la x cuadrada es negativo
entonces aquí solamente tenemos dos
posibles resultados estas dos que abren
hacia abajo ahora bien las dos tienen el
vértice en igual a 1 es decir 1 hacia
arriba por lo tanto no podemos asegurar
nada por ahí pero la gran diferencia es
que nosotros habíamos concluido que
estaba desplazada esta gráfica 1 hacia
la derecha porque cuando x vale 1 esta
expresión se hace 0 es justo lo que
vimos en el primer ejemplo
este mismo vídeo cuando x vale 1
entonces esto se hace 0 y la gráfica se
desplaza a la derecha y por lo tanto
aquí tengo que x vale 1 se desplazó la
gráfica a la derecha y la respuesta
correcta entonces es la cee y bueno yo
sé que cuando hablamos de desplazar una
gráfica tal vez sea la parte más difícil
de graficar funciones sin embargo te
recomiendo y te encargo que gráficas
funciones ya sean tomarte la gráfica
punto por punto o tal vez buscando algún
programa que grafique funciones para ver
cuál es la diferencia entre gráfica es
precisamente cómo está la cual está
desplazada a una unidad hacia la derecha
y la gráfica original y es igual a menos
2 x cuadrada más 1 así que nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo